[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
host of the Ken Coleman show Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
career and jobs and work expert is my
co-host today so if you want to talk
about those subjects he's here for you
anything else the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll talk about you right in front of
you Jordan is in Salt Lake City hey
Jordan welcome to the Ramsay show
all right thank you for having me sure
what's up
well I've been talking with my wife
about something for a while we have an
opportunity
to go and house it for her family down
in another city and we also have our
condo almost paid off
so we're in between decisions of
deciding to sell it and really roll that
to a new home or to rent it out and
again almost paid off so we collect
rents on that and be able to use that to
pay for a home as well so kind of in The
Crossroads there and figure to get your
opinion on it
okay so you're moving to a better house
the only question is whether you're
going to stop in between along the way
and house sit for a little bit
right well we are going to house it um
but the question is oh so there any
questions whether to keep the condo or
not
yeah keep the condo or rent it out and
really take the rents without a payment
on it yeah so how much do you owe on it
uh right now we are about 38 000 left oh
good good for you when will it be paid
off
uh we'll pay it off within the next few
months or so okay good good and what's
your household income
about a hundred thousand dollars a year
okay
and uh what will the property cost that
you're going to buy probably later
we'll ask a question we're probably
looking in the ranger between 300 and
400 000 for the next home okay
and you don't have that and you won't be
getting that anytime soon making a
hundred
right that's correct okay all right so
the net result of keeping the condo is
you're going to borrow more on the new
property
so it's as if you're borrowing on your
new property to buy a rental condo
you follow that logic yeah so given that
logic that says we're selling the condo
okay because if you had a if you had a
house let's say you had a 300 000 house
and you owed 100 on it and uh you kept
called me up and said I want to borrow
uh 90 000 bucks to buy a rental condo
against my personal residence I would
laugh at you right wouldn't I
sure yeah and and in essence that's the
net effect of this discussion if you
keep the condo so uh you didn't mean for
it to be that way but you just didn't
I'm reverse engineering on you to make
you see the logic of where I'm going so
I love the idea of rental property I
love rental estate but I'm not uh going
to keep a a condo
and um as a result borrow more on my
next property so yeah I think you're
right and what people need to think of
when you lay this out is what is
advancing me further down the road
towards my financial goals and selling
this condo does that they get to upgrade
massive down payment less of a hassle
it's just a win all the way across the
board and you get the next house paid
for real fast that's exactly right Nick
is in Chattanooga hi Nick welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey how's it going better than I deserve
what's up
so uh my prayer has been answered I uh I
got promotion at work and uh I'll be
doing a uh an apprenticeship of sorts
and ultimately you know five seven years
from now I want to have my own business
but start out as like a side hustle and
I want to know what steps did you take
knowing that's my end goal what would I
do for now until then what would be your
advice on that so what business are you
in now what's the apprenticeship in
it would be electrical work like a
lineman okay and is the goal to start
your own company in that same space
uh yes sir yeah so
how can you do that on the side is there
any kind of uh well that it comes down
to this how do you do that on the side
without burning yourself out and then
making sure that you aren't in any way
poaching clients from your from your
current employer that's the key and so
as long as there's not a conflict of
interest you're doing a really good job
where you are that apprenticeship is
preparing you they're paying you
essentially to eventually go out and do
your own thing and that's what's
beautiful about the trade so this is all
about balance and then ethics is the
short answer is that what you're asking
that's pretty much because a lot of it
is just uh you know knowing what you're
doing and how to do it and just having
time you know doing the job because
there's there's such a shortage of right
people do any kind of Labor of that kind
and uh yeah you know I know some people
that have done that and they they're
like look you know I work for somebody
it was awesome but whenever I work for
myself it just opened a lot more doors
so obviously doing it in a smart way not
saying okay I can get a loan for this
but oh absolutely no absolutely not like
covet happens and then all of a sudden
you're like uh oh right so I can't make
the payment so that's the way I want to
go about it well that's the way you
should go about it so let me speak to
the financial piece then so you need to
be patient financially and
professionally here you get in you learn
it you get really good at it you become
very dependable and now all of a sudden
you know I've got everything I need
skill and experience to do this on my
own and I keep socket away money I'm not
going to go into debt I'm going to work
my way into the side hustle becoming a
full-time gig now the advice I give for
people that are in trade specifically to
move from from full-time jobs side
hustle to working for themselves is once
you do the side Hustle the right way
you're not poaching clients you get out
there and I'd like to see you have six
months minimum of your salary in the
side hustle bank account minimum six
months is what I would prefer six to
twelve more towards the 12 would make me
a little bit more uh secure in stepping
out on my own so I've got a pipeline of
clients that I believe I can build on
and I've got six to twelve months of
salary make sure if you're gonna jump in
the boat that you get the boat close
enough to the dock before you jump
that's right yeah that's that's what
he's saying okay because sometimes
people go I think this is going to work
you know and all it gets wet you know so
no you you got to get the got to get the
income up on the side to where when you
make the move over you don't even feel
it make sure you're not doing anything
unethical and stealing your boss's
clients for to build your new business
that would be wrong
um and then the last piece is this that
I'll throw on top of this Nick one piece
of you going in business for yourself is
learning the trade
but running your business is not doing
electrical wiring running a business is
a different skill set and so you've got
to learn some things about running a
business in addition to learning the
trade
um so a lot of people you know good heat
and air technician goes and open a
business but doesn't know beans about
running the business and fabulous heat
and air technician but then they go out
of business because they don't know what
they don't know how to do the marketing
they don't take care of the accounting
and the taxes they don't know how to
hire and fire they sign up for stuff
they shouldn't sign up for they over Buy
on their tools and all these kinds of
things so you've got to start looking at
this also as you make this transition as
a business person not simply a Tradesman
so uh the tradesman's awesome but that's
when you're working for somebody else
when you start working for yourself now
you own your gig and you got to be able
to run it that's the deal this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today oramar is with us in
Canada hey olamar how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
how can we help
uh well
um I'm actually excited to be on this
phone call I can't believe I'm talking
to you guys but
um I'm calling from New Brunswick Canada
uh I actually moved with my family and
my two babies three and four from
Toronto escaping pretty much what was
happening over there uh a normal rundown
home was two million dollars we didn't
want to get into a mortgage like that
and because we had the freedom of uh
remote jobs we decided Well let's move
uh we wanted a more conservative place
as well so it's been amazing living here
but we purchased a house four hundred
thousand dollars last year uh it has
been a year and a half
and I feel like I'm on baby step number
zero
we are reading the book and we're doing
everything we can but we had a very bad
advice with our mortgage we went on a
variable rate last year and I just I
feel hopeless I don't know
how to even care through this so we've
done what we can and we got the book
from the church
um Total Money Makeover we've been
reading it but with two little ones it's
been tough and I just I don't know how
to deal and cope with
I guess paying the mortgage when we
initially budgeted for sixteen hundred
dollars and we ended up at a fixed rate
of actually we fixed the rate last week
and we ended up at 3 200. so you have a
three thousand two hundred dollar
mortgage and what is your income
uh so my husband
and I recently started out a work uh
with the same company actually and I'm
making
33.90 uh I'm not on payroll but I am
I've been with them for 10 months and
they are willing to put me on payroll
it's just it hasn't come to that yet
it's 33.90 an hour or 33 900 a year
no 30 so
3390 monthly plus uh 85 000 a year that
my husband earns which is I believe it's
4 900. a month so we're roughly around 8
000 to almost nine thousand dollars yeah
you're about 8 500 a month take on
paying you have a three thousand two
hundred dollar mortgage which leaves
five thousand dollars to pay the rest of
your bills why can you not do that
I know right I I we feel the same but
unfortunately since we got our home last
year we had a I don't know why we came
up with the bright idea that we wanted
to finish the basement that we had in
this house because we wanted to rent it
out we said well maybe let's do like a
side uh income and have
um someone be downstairs and so is it
finished or not
it is okay somebody living down there
don't finish it yeah finally okay and
how much are they paying you
twelve hundred dollars okay and so
that's another 1200 on the 8500 now what
other bills have you got other than the
3 200 what are the debt payments have
you got
uh insurance I believe is 240. no I'm
talking about debt and debt oh that it's
um
000 on a home credit line how much is
the payment on that
uh a lot just like like a hundred
dollars Eleven Hundred more maybe
because we really got the high yeah okay
1100 all right so that's 42 4300 okay
and what else yeah uh twenty thousand on
a credit card which I I don't know how
it even came to that okay
here's what's going on okay your brain
is scrambled eggs on this money stuff
because it's you're all over the place
just to talk to you and that's where all
your stress is coming from
okay so the numbers you've given me
because you haven't thrown me any
numbers here that don't work
you've got ninety seven hundred dollars
a month coming into this house counting
the 1200 rent okay the only numbers
you've given me are thirty two hundred
and Eleven Hundred going out
so when you just start
my turn just at the top of the page
write nine thousand seven hundred
dollars and then write minus thirty two
hundred minus Eleven Hundred minus a
little for insurance minus some
electricity and food and then I then
you're gonna go Hey where's all my dad
gum money going because that's where I'm
going right now I can't figure out why
you're stressed out about this you
should have plenty of money so what that
tells me is you guys are very
disorganized
you're very chaotic it's chaotic talking
to you I'm not being mean to you but
that's the that's what's happening it's
the stresses in the air I can feel it
and and honey you got to get this you
guys got to get if you if when you push
this down onto paper and transfer this
financial stress into actual arithmetic
the stress will start to dissipate
because you you are not out of control
here unless you've left out entire
segments in this conversation which is
possible but uh you've got there's
something about writing it down
that makes it come alive and makes it
get under control so RMR it's kind of
like
remember that time back in high school
Ken when you have a problem or you might
do it as an adult and you sit down and
with your friend who's going to help you
the problem and you tell them the whole
problem and by the time you actually put
it into cogent words you know the answer
and it's not a problem anymore your
friend doesn't have to say anything they
just got to look at you like you're an
idiot right and so
um or worse than that you write it down
if you write yourself a report on what's
going on by the time your brain goes
from jumble to verbal and then one more
step from verbal to written you have
processed this information very
thoroughly and the answer oftentimes
will appear right in front of you you're
on the other end of that Spectrum right
now orimar so you guys need a budget
that's what you need and your your time
is not being managed well your kids are
overrunning you things are I bet your
house is a mess
and so you know the chaos that's in the
air and when you get things orderly and
straightened up the calendar straight
the budget is straight you're going to
get on top of this and you're gonna be
able to run it's so fast because you're
really doing better than it feels like
you're doing to you
your numbers are not nearly as bad as
your emotions are telling you they are
yeah what I heard is someone who's being
reactive instead of proactive and the
power in writing it down and creating
this budget Omar what Dave's telling you
is right when you look at just that
exercise where he said all right let's
start with what's coming in you guys
have got to write down what's going out
and when you begin to get intentional
proactive versus reactive you guys are
letting every day come at you and I
don't think you have a plan at all
your emotions are meant not your logic
that's right so get your critical
thinking skills up on top of it yeah
open up an every dollar app get that
thing going
um you've got to know you've got a Total
Money Makeover book you and your husband
sit down turn the TV off put the kids to
bed tell them to stay in bed yeah and
we're going to sit here and we're gonna
read this book and we're gonna freaking
do these steps exactly we're gonna get
these forms out of the back of the book
even I don't care if you do it long hand
with a yellow Pad but when you get
organized you will feel more in control
and the reason you feel that way is
because you are more in control yeah and
it changes everything folks when you
jump on your every dollar app and do
your budget for the first time you say
this is how much is coming in and here's
where I know it's going and then there's
this big pile of money left over
you're gonna go what am I doing
I'm spending like I'm in Congress
what am I doing
you're going to have that moment where
you feel like you got a raise it's true
every dollar allows you to see where you
are and then you can start making
changes but the problem is when you
don't know where you are and what we
felt in her was this I just don't know
where any of it's going and I don't know
and I don't know and here's what we know
about just human psychology when the
scariest thing is the unknown and so
every dollar allows me to actually for
the first time go oh that's where I'm
spending money bad news is not nearly as
scary as unknown that is so true the
human brain reacts more aggressively and
positively towards bad news than it does
the unknown you might have cancer it's
going to be three weeks before you tell
you that's three weeks of hell yeah and
then they say you got stage three bring
on the chemo you're like at least I know
what it is the devil I know let's fight
it here we go game on but the unknown
will drive you bananas
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you are with us Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
with 19 service Brands Nationwide you
can help find Reliable help from great
locally owned businesses like air serve
Mr Appliance dryer vent wizard visit
neighborly.com today for help with just
about anything for your home today's
today's question comes from Brittany in
New Jersey I currently have a hundred
percent job satisfaction Brittany I
don't have that I know and she puts love
in all caps by the way I love my job
however I'm consistently being pushed to
take promotions that I do not want while
flattering I'm running out of ways to
say no politely is it wrong to stay at
the same level in my career how do I say
no to a promotion all right I love this
question Dave because I do think this is
a leadership flaw and it's pretty common
in America that when someone does a
great job we certainly want to reward
them and Beyond pay we end up pushing
them into positions many times that
they're not well suited for so Brittany
my answer is
um it's not wrong to want to stay in the
same seat on the bus that you really
love I think that's honorable uh and so
the second question is how do I say no
um I don't think you say no I think you
say thank you I am flattered I'm honored
I like being here I want to be on this
bus but I really love the seat that I'm
on here's why I love that seat and
because of that I don't want to step
into this promotion it's not because I'm
not willing to try it's not because of
this and this I just feel like this is
my Niche and I want to fill it and I'm
grateful for the opportunity but this is
what I want to do and I think that
that's shocking for a lot of leaders to
hear but I think you have to say it yeah
leaders uh assume that everyone wants to
move up and make more money but I'll
tell you where we mess this up in
leadership a lot is in the technical
field uh not everyone that likes
designing and writing code wants to lead
people that's right as a matter of fact
most of them don't want to lead people
uh not everyone in our creatives among
our video team and our uh our you know
the producing uh the graphics and and
the other work in this place a lot of
those prefer doing the creative work and
if they take a if they take a promotion
into leadership they often miss
doing the work that they love and so
creatives and Tech are the ones I've
seen it the most with the first time I
ever experienced this in leadership and
it's a little bit baffling for a young
leader or an immature leader was the
very first guy I ever hired Russ Carroll
oh yeah Russ came to us he was a former
pastor and he was doing uh counseling
Financial counseling one-on-one and he
loves sitting down and pastoring and
counseling loving people that were
hurting helping them you know not lose
their home get their budget organized
he's kind compassionate Guy and um you
know our company's blowing and going
growing and he was the very first guy I
ever hired and you know all of a sudden
there's 10 15 of us and we're like okay
we've got this department Rush that is
the counseling department and the Live
Events Department yeah and do you want
to come and take a promotion and run
that and he said wait a minute let me
get this straight I would not be doing
counseling anymore right he said and I
would be doing budgets yeah and I'd be
hiring and firing people and not have to
deal with their problems the the people
the employees problems I said yeah and
he goes that would be leukemia to my
spirit such a good line too wow and just
but he was self-aware enough and mature
enough to say no I get great joy from
coaching and counseling and he counseled
with that he worked for us 20 years
right that's right and that's what he
did the whole time yeah he did some
speaking outside of here and uh in terms
of we would send him to church to speak
for us and something like that and uh
and he did coaching and counseling never
once ran a department and you know many
many many people came and went running
departments for more money yeah but he
was very comfortable what he's doing and
it's sometimes baffling for someone in
leadership but uh Russ is one of my best
friends for this day I love the guy and
uh still honor him as our first team
member at Ramsey and he taught me that
lesson yeah yeah it feels nonsensical
folks because you're turning down an
opportunity to grow and we're people of
progress however Dave mentioned the key
word there it's maturity maturity to go
you know what I know who I am I know
what I want and I know why and and you
can say hey I'm honored and I hope
leaders would say you know what I
appreciate that we'll give you a bump
and pay because we want to reward you uh
but we're going to keep you there and
we're going to honor that and I think
that that is a healthy response to
someone saying that but you're right
Dave most leaders got to a leadership
position much the same way
they were they were like I gotta say yes
I'm an idiot if I don't yeah yeah how do
I turn this down just by saying no no
Langdon is in Paducah Kentucky hey
Langdon how are you
I'm doing well Dave and Ken how are you
all better than we deserve sir what's up
all right so I'm just going to lay the
foundation here before my question uh my
wife and I we each invest in our
employer's 401ks up to the uh match
percentage and what we put in goes into
the Roth option now we also we also each
have Roth IRAs on our own so this
morning we're having our budgeting uh
meeting and
we were discussing okay here's the
percentage we're going to start putting
into our Roth my wife being uh smarter
than me brings up the thought hey why
don't we just load up our work
retirement on account of it's already a
Roth option instead of putting it into
our separate Ross what's the pros or
cons or benefits of that and I said I'm
going to get an answer Euphoria today
and that's why I'm calling you guys okay
uh there's no difference if the mutual
funds are the same
if your work mutual funds perform as
good as your personal Roth mutual funds
there's no difference the only
difference is you got a little bit more
accessibility and control to personal
accounts than you do to business
accounts uh through your HR department
or whatever right but it's uh these days
with your web access and other things
with most 401ks it's just fine and as
long as you're getting a good a
performing set of mutual funds at work
there's no difference at all
um
what we would tell you to do is if
you're out of debt everything but the
house and you have your emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses will
be to take your total household income
times 15 0.15 yes sir and then I want
that much money going in some kind of a
Roth
with with a match first and after that
either one of these accounts is just
fine I wouldn't put more than 15 in
unless your home is paid off which is
baby step six is your home paid off
it is not paid off we refinanced to a 15
a couple years ago and I think we're on
track for about six to seven years on
that good for you and uh what's your
household income
income is right around a hundred
thousand I believe okay so fifteen
thousand bucks
yes sir yes sir and I guess it's in
theory the work uh our work employer we
can load that thing up to what was it 19
to 20 000. I'm telling you don't do that
that's exactly the point 15 000 total
between these four accounts and
everything above that that's your house
yes sir okay so first take first take
the match and then do either one of the
other roths there's not a wrong answer
unless your work has only bad mutual
fund options and then you would move
towards your individual Roth to avoid
those bad options even if it's got bad
options up to the match but if the
options are are weak then you would go
towards the personal otherwise those
baby steps work every time every time a
lot of proof a lot of years yeah it's
been happening a long time open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five now let me tell you the
story I don't know how old he is
but if you put fifteen thousand dollars
away and seven years later your home is
paid off uh in somewhere around the time
that your home is paid off you're
probably a millionaire
that would be normal that would be the
normal set of mathematics and so that
this just tells you how
quote unquote easy it is to become a
millionaire in America very very
important to focus and be intentional
which is not easy in a world full of
add this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today this is the Ramsay show thank you
for being with us Valerie is with us in
Boston hey Valerie how are you
sure
so I
am ages 15 and 16 two days ago I lost my
job
and so I had been with the company for
21 years
um I've been going to school full-time
while trying to resolve my husband's
estate and also really becoming a single
parent so my question is being that I
just lost my job my job basically was
the additional income that was allowing
me to cash flow school we do get my
husband's Social Security and so I'm
kind of on the fence as to what to do
now
um
I really wanted to finish pursuing
school to open up
my income potential and I'm just
concerned do I go out and try and find
another job right away to continue to
cash flow school do I just put 100
effort into school
possibly take off a small student loan
to get through I'm just not sure where
to go from here how much how much school
do you have left and what are you
attempting to get what degree and where
will that take you
um I'm going to school for pharmacy I'm
looking to get a pharmd because I've
been in the industry for 21 years okay
um and so it's it's it's going to allow
me to go into biomedical engineering to
work in the lab developing the
medications great
um I still have a good four or four and
a half years of school left
um and I and I've been doing the cheaper
route I've been doing community college
online classes so that I can try and
manage
you know the household all by myself
um what were you doing anything laid off
from
pharmacy technicians and what were you
being paid
um
over 27 an hour okay all right
and uh why were they laying people off
they weren't laying people off um it's
actually a payroll dispute which I'm I'm
appealing my termination with the
company they're saying that I
fraudulently got paid out vacation time
my supervisor paid vacation time that I
did not request and I have documentation
of that so I am appealing the
termination
um you know so that but that's it's a
hot mess
it's a very very large company but I am
appealing the termination because after
21 years I have an exemplary record it's
it's kind of ridiculous that with the
first offense they went right to
termination
oh and they didn't even investigate the
stupid Corporate America okay right
um exactly wow
uh okay what's the market like for Farm
techs right now I'm taking a stab that
that's uh it shouldn't be hard to get
shouldn't be hard for you to replace
that income correct
well it wouldn't be hard for me to
replace the income the difficult part is
scheduling because I am all by myself it
was all it was that way before though
yeah
true but the position that I just had my
direct Supervisor was extremely flexible
um and very understanding with
scheduling if I needed to fluctuate for
instance now it's a summertime
scheduling's a little bit different
versus during the school year
um once my son yeah but that's not to
say you can't find that again they may
be they may be uh
motivated enough for a hire that they
will work with you on flexibility so um
okay I think you need the income
and I think you're scared to go look for
another place because this uh in the
middle of all the pain and tragedy
you've already been through this is one
more kick to the gut yeah
it definitely is one more kick to the
Box before and it just kind of takes
some of your confidence away
yeah for sure and you've been with them
21 years don't and I'm trying to make
you feel good about this there's nothing
wrong with you but you've been in one
place 21 years that's a massive change
and so your brain has got to get to a
place where you go wait a second I can
be just as valuable somewhere else and
so this represents change it might be
really neat if you ended up making 37 an
hour yeah and this whole thing ends up
being what's called a blessing
a year I'm not I want you to go make 210
000 a year and not care about that all
right
okay don't let the government dumb down
your life
okay
yeah so that no you can make enough more
to offset anything they could and there
was there was no other estate when he
passed other than that
um there we have I have 374 000 in a
traditional IRA that I got from the
estate
um there's no debt at all we owe 116 000
on the house there are school I
apologize there's one debt for solar
panels that he has put on the house that
I only owe 29 000.
um I've been working on getting that
paid off but outside of that there's
zero debt anywhere else cars are paid
off
um everything else is paid off so I just
have
pretty much just those two payments and
the normal living expenses this is not a
math problem Valerie this is
um you've been uh you've had the
roughest two years of your life
including an unreasonable
uh bad poor weak leadership at a company
you worked for that fired you for no
reason
and the loss of your husband and these
are things that just steal some of your
confidence but if you if you just kind
of if you pretend for a second that
you're like uh 19 years old and the
whole world's in front of you and
everything the sun is shining and you
just run out there and grab you
something with a big smile on your face
you're probably going to get a raise
okay and you're probably gonna find
something with more flexibility than
those twerps you were working for
not if you make more than the Social
Security
okay and you will probably I mean let's
go find out what's out there yeah
instead of sitting in the corner
but it's it's but you it's a normal
human reaction to uh to to not feel
super confident in your situation that's
right
right but we're talking to a lady who's
super competent and so we see we're more
confident for you than your last two
years of your life have led you to feel
Valerie how much do you want to be in
that lab
four years from now how much you want to
be in that lab doing that kind of work
I would I would love to be there
especially after my husband passed away
from a very rare cancer
um and there's a limitation on treatment
options was huge so I it just kind of
motivated me even more to want to see
Valerie okay now listen that's what you
got to hold on to yeah when your future
when the excitement for your future is
greater than the fear of the unknown and
greater than the hurt of the past that's
when you are unstoppable and you have to
keep that future in mind four years goes
by quick you know that you're a mama
bear those kids were 10 and 12 and 11
you know and so four years no debt do
not opt for the student loan you don't
need it you got this far please don't
take the student loan
that's right yeah bet on Valerie is
she's a good bet yeah
that's where I'm placing my bet yeah and
it's not on Corporate America
this is the kind of stuff that makes me
want to spit Nails where you've got the
the uh her boss who gave her flexibility
gives her vacation time whether
fraudulently or accidentally and they
take it out on her she has an exemplary
record it's not like there's a pattern
of her doing this and she can't give
herself vacation time can't happen that
way now this is where HR gets a bad name
because there's idiots in there right
bunch of paper pushers instead of wait a
second let's look at who this person is
and 21 years and by the way here this
will get you in God will love you if you
mess with widows there's that too let's
just go ahead and do that let's just
mess with widows and orphans and see how
this turns out for you yeah good Lord 21
years she's been with us oh stupid
they're just stupid and then they want
you know I don't know how do you build
employee loyalty you don't pee on the
ones that you have hello try that
there's a good starting spot why is this
hard yeah goodness gracious we can't
attract good talents because you piss on
the ones you have it's just golly yeah
just dumber than a rock man
if she wins the appeal she's not going
to want to go back there because of how
they treated her on the front the only
reason I want our appeals get a dadgum
checkout that's what I want a nice fat
check yeah for on on you know for
yeah wow hey uh good riddance go make 37
an hour yeah I'm betting on Valerie
she's the horse gonna win this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
to work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Ken Coleman Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
our Ramsey career expert host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Julie
is in San Francisco hi Julie welcome to
the Ramsey Show
sure what's up
Okay so
2022 in Nevada
and I'm actually renting it right now
and it's making double my mortgage
payment which is great
but I also have parent plus phones that
total 178 000. my daughter graduated in
2021 she's doing well but she's getting
her Masters now which is totally under
her name but I've got these Parent Plus
Loans in my name
how's she paying for her Masters
yeah she is oh she's painful she's
paying for the Masters but I've got the
undergrad loans and then of course she's
got her own student loans within the
undergrad program yeah so your question
is do you sell your rental property to
clear 178 000 debt yeah yeah what's your
household income
um so I mine alone so I live with my
fiance mine alone is a hundred thousand
when are you getting married
we don't know yet we're trying to clear
all this stuff up
okay what does what does he make
um he makes about 120 plus
120 plus with the bonuses and stuff
and stuff actually can I tell you what I
used to make and this is part of another
part two question
I used to make 145
so when I moved in with him I took that
pay cut so I kind of we both want to
move closer to the city
to the to the bay and that will allow me
to get a better paying job and get back
to where I was before
because you changed locations
say that again you took a pay cut
correct okay yep I'm like two hours away
from the base so let's pretend for a
second
you do not own a house in our pretend
world for a second in Nevada okay
you have a 178 000 in Parent Plus loans
and I put two hundred thousand dollars
in cash in the middle of your kitchen
table
you have two choices you can buy a
rental property in Nevada or you can pay
off the parent plus loan
I know what you're gonna say I didn't
say anything I asked you a question
it's a leading question but I asked you
a question
well it's kind of obvious isn't it
yeah sell the house
when you decided to pay for your
daughter's education with borrowed money
you decided to get rid of this house now
you're actually having to admit it
yeah
it's gone
and you got your life back and you got
your life back for real really yeah
you're focusing on the house being gone
and that it seems like such a great
investment because it's paying you
double you're not focusing on the fact
that those loans are gone that's what
you should be celebrating you're feeling
sad about losing the house we should be
happy that you can get out of the debt
does that make sense and the next time
someone presents an idea to you to go
178 000 in debt just smile and say no
even if it's one of your kids
especially if it's one of your kids yeah
right yeah yeah even more so there we go
Eric is with us in Frankfurt Germany hi
Eric welcome to the Ramsay show
and Ken thank you for taking my call
sure how are you all today better than
we deserve what's up
love to hear it so me and my wife uh my
wife is active duty military and we have
been living in Germany for the past two
years and we will be here for another
three years until she retires
we just have our first child in May
after a long journey with IVF and are
currently 100 debt free wonderful
yes thank you thank you
um so our plan when she retires is to
move to Dallas and we're trying to
figure out how much money we should be
looking to spend on a house
uh when she does retire
well jump on Google and figure out what
the median house price in Dallas is but
the median house price nationally right
now is Touch under 400k
okay and that's median not average
average will be slightly lower than that
but the in other words half the houses
sell for more than that half the house
or so for Less that's median average
will be less but you know three to four
hundred K is an average home and a
typical uh city in America but certainly
there's neighborhoods in Dallas you
can't touch for that and there's plenty
of neighborhoods that are less than that
so you know absolutely depends on the
neighborhood there's three things
determine price of real estate location
location location location but yeah so I
think you start doing some research on
the area you're going to be moving to
and that helps you set some goals and uh
let me maybe I should rephrase my
question a little bit so I we currently
have 200 000 saved and
um by the time she retires I'm kind of
projecting us to have about half a
million to about 550 saved good
um when would you see anything wrong
with us if we were to pay cash for a
house if we were to spend that full
amount you called Dave Ramsey and asked
him if it was okay to pay cash I know
from Germany
I did
I'm on the edge of my seat Dave what's
the answer what's the answer I can't
wait of course you pay cash yeah that's
exactly what I would do and the reason I
would is because now with no house
payment and this fabulous ability to
manage money and save money you guys are
going to be able to pile up an
incredible Nest Egg incredible wealth
and be a blessing to your kids your
family your future family your change
your family tree and many families
around you because you're going to be
very wealthy you guys are incredible
thank you for serving your country
congratulations on the new baby stack
cash come to you come back to us after
uh retirement and in a couple of years
and and pay cash for a nice house and
then become very outrageously wealthy
and outrageously generous you guys are
amazing way to go
yeah incredible stuff now here's what I
want to ask you uh what is it that's
behind that question he knows
fundamentally what you're going to say
but what's the fundamentally it's it's
yeah everybody knows what I'm gonna say
that's right I'm I'm really not known
for anything else right
um but there's a fear like it's just
what Bill tell his buddies
buddies are saying I'm an idiot ah okay
I was wondering Dave Ramsey said pay
cash yeah yeah I just want to make sure
still after 30 years of saying it over
and over and over again he still says
pay cash
but yeah that's it that's the thing this
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
foreign
buying Market but there's a way you can
get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we could use your help you want
to help us we would appreciate it
since you pay so much to listen to the
show and uh here's here's what it's
going to cost you you need to jump on
and however you are viewing the show
subscribe or follow or whatever it means
wherever you're watching as you're
listening to us also share the show
click the share button let some friends
know about the show or tell people about
us however you it is you want to go
about sharing it that's fine we'd love
to have you do that and of course where
you can leave a five-star review all of
that is very helpful thank you Kathy is
in North Carolina hi Kathy welcome to
the Ramsay show
hello thank you Dave for taking my call
my pleasure to get to talk to you yes
and Ken I think that's who you said Ken
yes it's me I'm here Kathy today for you
what's going on
okay so my husband and I retired we're
age 65 and 68.
we live in our mortgage-free home that's
valued at just under 500 000 and we're
debt free
our yearly income is about a hundred
thousand with retirement so secure
Social Security
pension and we have a seventeen hundred
dollar a month rental property that
your phone broke up wait a minute stop
stop stop your phone broke up you have a
1700 a month rental property it's paid
for too
yes okay good now you're not gonna hear
you again and he has like oh good he has
about 500 000 and third savings that
invested conservatively and his pension
and our social security that's what
makes up the hundred thousand
okay great so
um we live in North Carolina just off a
very popular place called Topsail Island
and people flock here throughout most of
the year
and I've been wondering if it would be
smart to invest in an Airbnb rental and
the one I'm looking at is about 280.
and you're going to take out enough of
his Thrift Savings to buy it
no no we'll we'll
um we'll borrow against our house
[Music]
um
no no but equity line or anything yeah
you have a very good life don't go screw
that up with an Airbnb
no I knew you were gonna didn't say that
ah there it is
let's see if you want to buy an Airbnb
if you want to buy a rental for an
Airbnb take enough out of his Thrift to
do it pay cash for it
would okay how long have you had this
other room
oh
oh okay hey can you tell me some tenant
horror stories
you know what we have been so blessed
I've only had
okay good out of all
keep in mind when you have an Airbnb you
have a new tenant every four days
yes yes yes
we're talking hassle Factor right we're
talking hassle Factor we're talking risk
factor uh damage uh police being called
uh neighbors griping at you uh all kinds
of stuff that you hadn't even thought
about and we're talking about you're
gonna make a whole lot more money than
you would have just rented that house
but you are getting ready to start a new
small business
that's what renting it renting an Airbnb
is
yeah I understand that yeah and and so
this is not like I'm going to just go to
the mailbox and collect a bunch of
checks because Airbnb is a big deal now
it's not it's it's a lot of work
and they're going to tear up your
property and you're going to put it back
and then they're going to pay for it and
then you're gonna you're gonna be yeah
it's it's a lot of work it's like it's
very similar to run the hotel
I mean you know your husband is going to
be set
glad for when I tell him
well I I wouldn't I wouldn't do it good
idea yeah if I were in your shoes you
sound like you have a very
simple fun clean life that's very secure
I wouldn't put this beehive in the
middle of it if it was me uh but uh if
you want to go make some money you can
make some money with this but you know
that you're dealing with Hassle and the
only way you want to do it is to pay
cash just something to share with Kathy
and other people that may be getting bit
by the Airbnb bug and you think it's a
sure thing you might be late to the
party yeah you are because we're seeing
some new rev uh some new Revenue data
here all the rooms which kind of checks
listings and revenue we've seen
significant drops this year compared to
2022 places like Austin uh Sevierville
Tennessee which is 2R East uh you're
seeing 47 drops San Antonio Texas 43
drop Nashville 39 drop Denver 38 New
Orleans Seattle Washington there's more
and more cities here and so the point is
there's a glut right now of people who
got into these as Investments much like
you're thinking about Kathy Nashville's
down Nashville's down 30 bachelorette
party yeah keep it going Phoenix
Arizona's down because people don't want
to burst into flames apparently uh
Austin Texas one of the hottest cities
in the Flames have you heard about the
Chamber of Commerce well I mean I'm
telling you it's so hot out there right
now people are reading about this but
anyway here's the point you're talking
about major markets throughout the
country where there is more Supply than
there's demanding you can get caught
really quickly man there there's
starting to be a backlash both
politically like people are calling
zoning on it and they're saying some
some cities have passed it's just
illegal period uh and so I'm not sure
that's constitutional but a lot of
zoning stuff's questionable so they pull
off all kinds of crap in the name of
protecting other people but it's called
civilization I think but um but they uh
they regulate our butts off but the uh
uh yeah so it's you know
um the bottom line is is the Airbnb
market is soft
and there's a lot more work involved and
a lot more risk involved than people uh
ascribe to it if you properly address
the market and say given that it's soft
the article Ken's reading given the high
level of work and Hassle and the risk of
damage
and the risk of the whole thing and pay
cash for it if you Embrace every bit of
that and still want to do it I'm on your
team go do it
because you'll make a lot more money
I'll give you another one okay if you
want to make more money on residential
real estate buy cheap houses in bad ends
of town low income rentals give a much
higher Roi rate of return rent to Value
than high income rentals do in the rich
into town Rich into town you don't
really make that much money on a rental
doesn't do as good but guess what you've
got a higher hassle Factor right you're
dealing with people tearing up stuff
you're dealing with them running drugs
or prostitution out of your house or
running you're dealing with all this
other crap potentially I used to have a
whole bunch of those properties that's
all I know but I mean I had one house
that I paid eleven thousand dollars for
now this was a long time ago right but I
paid eleven thousand dollars for it and
the rent I got on it per month was
fifteen hundred wow now you can't touch
that right but I'm telling you man I had
to collect my rent on the doorstep every
Friday afternoon or they would snort it
or drink it over the weekend you know I
mean it was like so it's a different
you're just dealing with a different
thing so if you want to engage in hassle
to make more money you can engage in
hassle to make more money in this Airbnb
right yeah uh but but if you don't if
you want something has a she's kind of
her life is so dialed in yes so sweet
yeah everything's sitting there paid for
and she's collecting this rent and had
very little hassle for so for 20 years
only one bad story
yeah don't screw that up I I
this is a Sesame Street moment one of
these things is not like the other you
know it doesn't fit in this equation
she's fun though apparently her husband
is going to be very happy with that
advice so that's
well maybe I don't know yeah he was like
I don't know I'm gonna call Dave and see
what he thinks let's see how this works
out but there we go fun fun fun good
stuff good stuff so guys the real estate
market is Shifting and so is the stock
market if you haven't noticed and most
of you haven't because 100 of the time
the stock market's down they do a lot of
news reports on it 100 of the time it's
up they almost never mention it
in the last 12 months the S P 500 12
months from today 12 months ago is up
16.4 percent if you were invested in a
very basic mutual fund for the last 12
months you would have made 16 on your
money anybody else tell you that no they
don't report this this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
well about eight years ago I looked up
on Twitter
in fact when I looked at Twitter and uh
there were some guys on there poking fun
at all kinds of people and then the next
thing I knew they're making fun of me
and they're funny as crud and some of my
favorite follows on social media the bee
The Babylon B Kyle Mann one of the
founders of the Babylon b along with his
friend Adam uh who's gone on to do other
things now but they started this thing
over in California and uh a satirical
look at a church for one thing and
church making fun of us church people by
church people because you're a pastor's
kid I know you are a pastor you're a
pastor yeah you're a pastor at one point
my dad's a rocket scientist oh well
there's that wow for real yeah
that wasn't a joke you know not
everything I say is that's right right
well I'm just checking I didn't know if
you're pulling all right sorry Kyle man
is the editor-in-chief of the bee The
Babylon bee uh around here all the
Ramsey folk are big fans of the bee and
uh we recommend you guys check it out if
you want to have a good Snicker a good
laugh enough uh a couple times a day and
you ought to get something positive out
of social media so there's a way you can
do it so welcome Kyle good to have you
we're big fans man good to be here
thanks Dad thanks for having me so fake
news you can trust all right did Trump
steal that from you or did you stealer
from Trump
that's ours man it's copyrighted yeah we
made the T-shirt so we own the phrase
but fake news he stole from you fake
well no he's still fake news okay that's
what I thought yeah but we owe him no
royalties on it but fake news you can
trust yeah that's all because you can't
trust all the fake news
great great play great satire I mean
you've got a sense of humor a lot I mean
sarcasm is my uh my love language so I
love the whole thing and you guys have
come at me a bunch of times and I've
loved every bit of it it's we always get
good response uh uh because you're not
too hard on me but uh but you get a good
use so honestly you didn't want us to be
here no I appreciate it I know he's
trying not to make you mad yeah I don't
I don't I don't want I don't need
anybody else picking on me out there so
uh but satire is tough I mean it's hard
is it harder to create satire
uh when real life things are so over the
top I mean it's so weird out there that
it's like reality is satire yeah uh GK
Chesterton wrote 100 years ago that he's
he thought satire would be impossible
because the real news was so absurd you
wrote that in like 1911. and you picture
how crazy the news has gotten from 1911
until 2023 you know you just you open up
the news and you can't tell if it's a
real news headline or the Babylon B
headlines sometimes I can't tell and I'm
writing the the headlines yeah you know
that's how difficult it is yeah we I
mean when I was a kid the local
newspaper you might not agree with their
politics but it was least objective the
CBS Nightly News with Walter Cronkite
was at least objective but if I look at
CNN's website Fox's website look at the
local newspaper here in Nashville uh it
more resembles the National Enquirer
when I was a kid than it did then it
does I mean even their their look tone
feel their fonts and everything it's
it's just so salacious so bizarre as the
aliens you know that was I was reserved
for that was reserved for the National
Enquirer in the line when you're buying
groceries you know yeah but it has all
shifted that way to where you know it
you guys probably get confused for real
stuff sometimes don't you oh absolutely
yeah we've been fact checked dozens of
times our jokes get fact checked by
Snopes USA Today of course all different
kinds of outlets fact check our jokes
because people think they're real what's
the most famous case of a story being
taken very seriously well Snopes fact
checked one of our articles that was uh
CNN purchases industrial washing machine
to spin the news
somebody actually checked on that and
that got fact checked and our Facebook
page got demonetized de-platformed you
know all of that stuff because of that
article because it was fact checked and
they said oh you guys are sharing fake
news
yeah that's a joke because CNN yeah
CNN really didn't do that who knew yeah
as far as we know yeah yeah as far as we
know as far as we're in the campus is
there anything off limits for you guys
or how what's that editorial process
like when I I even hate to say editorial
but there is a version of that yeah well
we won't be too mean to Dave Ramsey
that's our number one we like that we
like that that's our number one rule
no using for clicks and laughs just
clicks and laughs all friendly stuff but
uh no I mean I don't think there's any
topic that's off limits for the satirist
and honestly that's why you know a lot
of left-leaning Comedy these days isn't
funny anymore because they have so many
no-fly zones things that they won't make
fun of that it doesn't surprise you
anymore yeah you know imagine if they
were to make fun of their own world view
you know things in their own world view
it would be shocking because they don't
do that you know so I think you do need
to be able to make fun of yourself you
do need to be able to make fun of things
in the culture
um I mean I just think the main the main
guideline that we use is that if we're
making fun of a serious topic like we're
trying to call attention to a really you
know heavy topic like abortion or
something along those lines then our
jokes are going to be that much more
serious you know we don't want to make
people think that we're making light of
those things sure right so that's kind
of one of the one of the guidelines that
we use yeah but you are an equal
opportunity offender I mean you go after
just about everybody enjoy one way or
another you make fun of fox or CNN yeah
right or left issues or uh you know uh
you know conservatives do this or or uh
you know lefties do this or whatever I
mean you you get on there it's fun yeah
well and you have to like I think to be
a good satirist you have to first be
able to laugh at yourself you have to be
able to make fun of your own and that's
what you know that's what made the
Babylon B get so popular so fast because
we were writing the the jokes about the
worship leaders who wear the v-necks and
all that oh yeah yeah absolutely and our
friend Dave Ramsey here yeah you know
those kind of jokes showed people like
hey they're not afraid to make fun of
themselves and that kind of gives you
the right to then go after the other
side a little bit too all right so I
gotta know this if you look to the
recent past or maybe a hundred years ago
as a satirist who would you have loved
to been in the public scene now where
you could have taken a crack at them
whether that be in the faith-based world
politics Sports what comes to mind when
I ask you that yeah so we launched we
launched like right at the end of the
Obama Administration you know and so we
were kind of like during the Trump
Clinton year so we did kind of launch it
in the perfect time when it was like you
could make a lot of good fun at Trump if
you had a good sense of humor about them
and you can make a lot of fun of Hillary
obviously too right um so we launched it
kind of that perfect time but yeah the
last the last hundred years I mean it
would have been great to be around in
the 80s with Reagan yeah I mean the
Clinton years you got people had so much
fun with on SNL but that's back when SNL
used to make fun of both sides and you
know they would back on SNL was fun it
was right back when the late night
people would make fun of both sides you
know George W bush obviously was great
for humor just with his mannerisms oh
yeah so we kind of missed out on a lot
of that but at the time there were
comedians covering it you know there was
the SNL and the late nights that were
actually doing that stuff you know I
remember him telling the story when I
was interviewing him about strategory
yeah yeah he thought he actually thought
he he said I thought I did say that and
he was talking to the writer at Saturday
Night Live Lauren whatever are the
people sure yeah and Lauren said No
George I said that I said you said that
but you never really said that and he he
owned it he thought he said I thought I
said it it was the funniest thing ever
and so yeah but that you got to be able
to laugh at yourself in the process you
got to be able to enjoy that ride no
question about it so um how do you
determine uh you guys put content on
almost all the major platforms uh from
podcasts to posts on Facebook posts I
guess you're you're banned from Facebook
no okay not bad from Facebook okay all
right but are you banned from anything
right now
um
we got banned from Tick Tock which is
you know a good thing in some ways yeah
because then you don't have to be on
Tick Tock yeah but uh I think we got let
back on so I don't know if we're
actually banned from anything right now
look what got you banned from Tick Tock
and you can't joke about anything on
Tick Tock you know we'll do jokes about
the the tamus joke you can imagine and
they'll say you know community community
standards politically sensitive
politically sensitive you know what's
crazy about that is they won't let you
make fun of anything but they'll let
kids go on and say stupid crap about
time blindness and how she's mad at her
boss this is the latest rage
this will make Dave's head explode I'll
have to tell him during the commercial
break he can't handle it on the air it's
too much but they'll let kids rage yeah
but you can't make a joke yeah well
that's part of the danger of social
media and algorithms who's controlling
the algorithm and controlling what we
see we already know that with Tick Tock
you know they change the algorithm based
on who you are if you're in America if
you're in China yeah the algorithm is
different based on what they want to
produce in the culture so so how do you
guys with all those different platforms
determine which piece of content worked
um I mean there there's some there are
some social media platforms where uh a
certain joke will hit a little a little
bit better like for a long time Twitter
was kind of the political space where
yeah politics jokes did well yeah you're
a big hit on Facebook and Instagram for
us
I love of it that's good okay good so
yeah it just depends on the audience and
where they are well we're just here to
serve I'm saying yeah Dave you
Dave from the Graham as the kids
huge on the B baby that's it that's what
I'm saying uh Babylon B Kyle man thanks
for stopping by brother we love your
work it's a lot of fun you guys if you
haven't followed it jump in and follow
you'll get a laugh and uh you might get
offended and that'll be good for you too
just laugh your way through it you gotta
love it the Babylon bee check it out
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Janet is in Boise
Idaho hi Janet welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Ken and Dave it's a pleasure ours
too how can we help
yeah so I'm calling today just to see
how we as we as me and my husband can
get ahead of our bills it seems like
every single month we pay our bills
three weeks after the due date and then
a week later they're due again
so we've tried you know budgeting and
just trying to get ahead and we just
can't seem to get that curve um
so we're going to calling to see what
tips and tricks you could provide for us
what's your household income
it's about 75 000 gross
how much debt do you have not counting
your house
39 000 on what
on student loans is twenty four thousand
five thousand in credit cards and a 9
000 or 10 000 on the RV travel trailer
on a trailer okay and you make 75k a
year that's right between the both of us
okay
all right
um
all right so where do you think your
money's going
to go keep you like the baby steps I've
been doing it probably by myself for
like a whole year
um ever since and it seems like actually
we've been on this momentum of just
being behind for like the last year and
we're just sick of it I'm tired of
handling it so I have him stepping in on
the finances
as well as just really you know being
careful with where our money is going
and so you know I've tried for the last
two months these have just been you know
paying every single week um could we get
paid every week so that's kind of so if
I sat down with you and your husband
with a yellow pad at the kitchen table
and I said okay this is what you have
coming in this week let's let's map out
where every one of those dollars is
going this is what you have coming in
the next week let's map out where every
one of those dollars is going let's map
out you you should have enough with the
numbers you gave me we should yeah we
should and that's but you're not doing
that
right there it is okay
so you need you need to sit down and you
can jump on every dollar but the number
one the first thing is the two of you
have to do this together not turn it
over to him because he because he can do
it and you can't do it that's not true
okay both of you together need to do
this because what's going to have to
happen is you're gonna have to decide
not to do a bunch of stuff you're doing
now that does that doesn't matter as
much as getting in control matters
right I want to get in control more than
I want to go out to eat I want to get in
I want to get out of debt and have a
life more than I want to go on vacation
uh I want to get in control more than I
like this travel trailer I want to get
in control more than and I'm sick and
tired of living stress to stress to
stress to stress to stress with no hope
feeling like a rat in a freaking wheel
and when the both of you when both of
you are saying that and then you put
numbers to that and you say okay this
week on Friday we get a check for X the
following Thursday we get a check for
why the following Saturday we get a
check for Z and you write that down and
you plan out every one of those dollars
and where every one of them are going
because the water bill is due on the
second week the house payment's due on
the first week the uh student loan
payments due in the third week and we're
going to figure out what's coming out
we're going to take this much for food
this much for food this much for food in
the four different weeks and we're gonna
allocate every one of those bills to a
certain week and some of them across
weeks so that we have enough money to
take care of them and every dollar has
an assignment on paper on purpose before
the month begins we agree on it and spit
shake and pinky swear and then we don't
do anything else with money except what
we freaking wrote down
right and it seems like we've been doing
that for the last two months but we
can't catch that occur we can't get out
of here so you write it all down and you
don't have enough
no we do have enough but it seems like
it's gone every single week now if you
wrote it down to have enough and then
you did something else other than what
you wrote down
well I guess we're struggling is just
like every time we do try to we pay we
get our bill every single you know
whatever a month we pay it once a week
and but we have so many little ones it
seems like we just don't know where
they're not all written down prioritize
them yeah we need to prioritize them
better every one of them
on paper
on purpose in a certain week this is a
week one bill this is a week four bill
this is a week two Bill different bills
have different weeks and they all go
within the income of that week and then
when the check comes in the check is
already spent so you can't do anything
except what you wrote down you are not
managing to the budget you're writing it
out as a hypothetical and then going
doing what you used to do
right and you're not focusing on get
ahead but listen I'll tell you how
you've got it that'll get you ahead
that's what I told you yeah if you you
won't write down not getting ahead
you'll get a hit as soon as you do that
you've got room in this budget
yeah
you're disorganized and chaotic yeah and
when you give every single if I paid you
a hundred thousand dollars a year to pay
these bills exactly on time and you had
no emotional tied to them whatsoever and
you would look at this family this
distant family over in Boise Idaho and
tell them to quit going to freaking
restaurants I don't care how tired you
are no whining aloud you're going to pay
the freaking bill on time if I told you
to do that you could do it for someone
else
right it's because it's not right it's
sixth grade math
you can do this so you have got to get
very detailed very intentional and then
live the detail
don't write it all down and then go do
what you used to do
and so well I just I I didn't feel like
cooking tonight I don't give a crap go
home and get some leftovers out of the
dead gum refrigerator
that's how you do it you can't I mean we
all have that you just got to talk to
your whiny self and say no whiny self
I've done that myself I mean Sharon I've
done it to each other we know what it
feels like but you have to go I want
control more than I feel tired tonight
you know and that's the biggest thing
that's the phrase that comes out of
everybody's mouth by the way before they
go out to eat or before they hit the
fast food and get dog food at Taco Bell
you know or whatever and so it's just
it's horrible it's horrible value it's
horrible nutrition and it's out of
control spending and so it's just yeah
see you've got to write it down and get
on every dollar download the app and I
tell you what I'll give you the upgrade
I'll give you the premium every dollar
where it ties to your bank
and we'll get you started on that Janet
because what you all desperately need is
a detailed budget and here's how you do
a budget folks you give every single
penny a name
every bill has a week allocated in every
dollar it's called paycheck planning and
you plan out each paycheck for the month
and you and your spouse both look at it
every dollar is assigned to saving to
giving or to a bill
period every single dollar there is no
missile there is no uh well fifty
percent of my budget is not allocated
bull crap allocate every dime
in every dollar on the paycheck planning
every dollar has a name before the month
begins August is coming where's your
August money going to be it's going to
freaking disappear if you don't tell it
what to do it will leave and go to
people's houses who tell it what to do
and then you'll say stuff like the poor
get poorer and the rich get richer yes
they do because the rich tell their
money what to do yeah that's how this
works and so you got to get on top of
this stuff and lean into it every dollar
has an assignment you stick to it you
agree on it with your spouse and you do
not spend a dime unless it's on that
page on that every dollar app if it's
not on there and it comes up and it's a
surprise and you forgot it you got to
take something else off because if you
put something on there and you're
already spent it all now you're in
overdraft and now it doesn't work and I
can't seem to get caught up well you're
not getting caught it because you're not
living your plan do the plan live the
plan write the plan live the plan do the
plan live the plan live the plan and
it's your plan by the way you decide
where it's going to go but I'm telling
you what I'm doing I'm not going out to
eat I'm not going on vacation I'm
selling a stupid travel trailer
everything else is for sale so much the
kids think they're next we're going to
take extra jobs and we're getting
control because I'm tired of being
stressed out that's what I'm doing if
I'm in your shoes and I did it by the
way this is the Ramsay show foreign
[Music]
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show for we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality host of
the Ken Coleman show and author of the
number one best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money thanks for hanging
out with us triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five North Dakota starts off this hour
Samuel is with us hey Samuel how are you
hey pretty good
how can we help
hey
um real quick
um
I've been married three years and uh we
had just brought in a modular home in
our uh I guess in the second year of
marriage
um and modular home mobile home Harvard
people call it um anyways
um the lot rent keeps raising up and
we're wondering if we should just
salad or what we should do with it and
like the other thing that I wanted to
mention is that we're expecting our
second child and so that kind of
throws it into the mess of the stuff as
well so it's getting some insight as far
as where I what I should do next
good for you
cool how old are you
uh 24. what's your household income sir
um 50 52
um for myself but then
me and my wife were the baby BL 64. okay
good
all right well the premise is this
um there's nothing uh on fire there's no
emergency here but 10 years from today
owning us owning a mobile home that goes
down in value is not a good plan
they go down in value you know that
yes yes okay thank you okay and so
instead I would rather be living in
something that goes up in value
and so that's why mobile homes are not a
good purchase simply it's a car you
sleep in it goes down in value so
um the you got to decide then you know
how since it's not a good long-term plan
when is the most opportune time to move
out of that and what are the steps it
might be that you sell it and it may
take you a little while to clean up you
may be upside down on you may owe more
on it than it's worth art do you
sorry what was the question do you owe
more on it than it's worth
no I do not okay what is it worth
the next Storehouse is about the same
layout as bar layout and it sold for uh
um and we owe about 40 on it right now
okay so hopefully you could get 50 and
walk away with 10 that would be amazing
and then what would we do are you out of
debt except for that
um we just have one One car loan okay
I'd clean up the car alone I'd build an
emergency fund and I'd rent for a year
to two years well I saved up a down
payment to buy my first home that is a
stick built
would or whatever home that's going up
in value
and if it takes you from 24 to 26 to
make that transition in one move that's
not a bad thing your other options sit
there and let this thing go down in
value and you're going to look up and
it's going to be worth 30 and you owe
35.
and then you're going to look up and
it's going to be worth 10 and you owe
25.
that's where it's headed long term
agreed
agreed yeah that's not a long-term plan
so again but again this month next month
I don't care the next month I don't care
somewhere in there uh when's the baby
due
in February okay
so if you're going to do it you should
do it immediately or you should do it
after the baby
okay if you could get a buyer now and
move into a rental with ten thousand
dollars in your pocket or how much you
owe in the car
nine thousand you have any money in
savings
yes I do how much
seven seven perfect good okay so if we
sell this and we put 10 in our pocket
that's 17 pay off the car now we've got
eight in savings and no debt and we're
renting when the baby comes that sounds
pretty good move now then we start
saving like crazy above our emergency
fund for a down payment on a home and
that might take you a year or two years
but that's what lots of couples do
yeah yeah and but what you're having to
do is change direction because you you
got to get off at the next exit because
you realize you're heading the wrong way
on the interstate
and the first step is to get off the
exit go under then get back on going the
other way
and that you know that that's what we're
doing we're stopping and heading back
and then and then we'll see how much how
long it takes us to get back up to speed
yeah Sam I don't know what's keeping you
from doing this you didn't say there was
anything but I'm telling you I would do
it now the baby on the way I do it
immediately get the transition underway
one transaction takes care of all of
your debt and now you're changing your
season you're getting at a nice
apartment you're gonna rent I just love
this move now I wouldn't wait I really
wouldn't especially since you've got a
unit next to you that just sold for 50.
I'd be moving on that yeah and you know
put this one on the market for 52
tomorrow
and now again if it gets up if it
doesn't sell yet and it gets up to
Christmas and it hasn't sold and she's
got a baby coming in February take it
off the market yeah where the left for
the baby comes do it this time next year
you know do it next summer that's fine
I'm good with it there's again there's
no emergency here but we need to be
making steps because what happens is
people put They Kick the Can on down the
road and they put off taking the steps
to move in the right direction and and
that will get you absolutely burned
so I've got a friend that uh is a mobile
home manufacturer and uh he's like would
you quit being so hard on us and I'm
like well I you know you know because
they really make some very nice mobile
homes now I mean like it's not like but
but you know I don't care if you call it
a modular home or you call it a mobile
home or you call it a trailer it goes
down in value if you can walk up to it
and perceive that it was built in a
factory
so you know if the home was brought in
on a truck baby you're going to have
trouble okay with the thing going up in
value because the marketplace doesn't
that the marketplace does not treat that
as a value increasing situation well I
know one that sold for yeah well the
reason it sold for that was the land
under it went up
it was sitting on five acres and the
five acres went up faster than the
mobile home went down
and that's why they got appreciation on
it so if it had a regular house sitting
on it they'd made even more so mobile
homes go down in value not a good plate
not a good thing to do don't buy one
don't buy one
and I'm not mad at you if you're in the
mobile home industry but you sell
something that goes down in value
don't buy one no buy a house or rent
until you can buy a house
that goes up in value it's the problem
with the tiny house movement
we've yet to see that the things are
going to appreciate yeah it's a novelty
a gimmick
and until it's got a proven track record
of appreciating going up in value
uh appreciating I'm not doing it this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Andrew
is in New Mexico hi Andrew welcome to
the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
partner and I are looking by a home in
the near future and I was just wondering
what the balance between you know how
much I should be investing how much I
should put towards my student loans and
then how much I should put towards
increasing the down payment on the house
good question okay well what we teach
folks is the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth and stability
with your money without a bunch of risk
is first to clear debt because your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income
then have a good solid emergency fund
then save up a down payment for a home
and then you would start or while you're
saving up for the down payment for the
home or after either one one of those
two you would start saving for
retirement so that sounds like this pay
off the student loan
first build an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses second that's
baby step three we call it then you
would
um go from there
and either go to baby step four which is
fifteen percent of your income or we
call saving for a home because it's a
temporary step baby step 3B so you can
stop all retirement not start retirement
and save aggressively for a home or you
could put some in retirement and save
some towards a home at that point so
that that's how we teach to do it and
we've taught tens of millions of people
to do that and it works beautifully it's
not necessarily popular because
everybody wants to go buy a house but
you need to get rid of these student
loans because they're not going anywhere
until you get rid of them and so that's
your first goal is to get your life back
from Sallie Mae most people don't do
that but most people are broke
and most people make a lot of money and
have nothing to show for it work their
whole life and then hope the government
which is well known for its ability to
handle money will take care of them
so don't do that
hang on I'll send you a copy of the book
The Total Money Makeover Andrew to show
you exactly how to do this process
Bridget is in Boston hi Bridget how are
you
hi I'm great thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
um so I had a question about
um saving money versus putting
um more into my 403b plan through work
um so I've always been like big into
saving money so I've always had a big
savings account
um I only recently started listening to
your show and learning more about
investing for the future so I'm just
sort of wondering
um I've I'm sort of like behind for the
year because I was only contributing
like I don't know five percent and that
was that like my part-time job so I only
have like 2500 that I put into it this
year but I know now that the max is like
22 500 so I'm sort of wondering if I
should be aggressive for like the rest
of the year and every year moving
forward to make sure I at least like Max
that out before I'm like piling up more
savings essentially you got any dad
except your home
uh no just a mortgage okay all right and
what's your income household income
uh my household income between my
husband
and play around three hundred thousand
way to go very cool okay so just like
the last caller we would tell you to
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses do you have that
uh yes we have like well over that
actually how much do you have in that
account
uh we have right now 125 000 I think
it's that okay that's where you said I
like being a saver
yes yeah because I know that's more than
we would ever need but it's way more
than you whatever so yeah what what do
you owe on your home
uh four hundred thousand perfect
man wouldn't it be cool get that house
paid off Bridget
yeah so that was sort of my dilemma
because we already actually made an
additional payment towards our home
earlier this year um of like 50 000 and
I was ready to do that again towards the
end of the year we were gonna like try
to just do like 100 this year because we
had the money too and the savings
accounts
um but but I'm sort of like wondering if
first I should max out my retirement
fund contributions and like prioritize
that and then
and then deal with a mortgage afterwards
and yeah
you can do both both you've got the
money
yeah let's sit down you and your husband
and lay out a game plan with the income
you have coming in and allocated I want
you to put 15 you said you're making
300K right
that's forty five thousand dollars
into some kind of retirement Investments
this year
15 of your income into retirement okay
and then everything else goes at the
house
and you only need three to six months of
expenses set aside it does not cut I
mean three six months of expenses at
your place is
probably 40 or 50 Grand
yeah that's what I was thinking like
around 50. let's hold 50 and throw the
rest of it at the house today
and I want you to cash flow forty five
thousand out of your income into
retirement by the end of the year
okay yeah my husband does get some
through his work plans like I'm only
speaking for my myself and I want you to
work on the household you have to work
together okay it's your marriage okay
you're married so we're gonna work
together okay and you're okay you're not
joined it's not a joint venture so I
mean if he's putting in more you're
putting in less or you're putting in
more he's putting in less I don't care
but the whole thing totals up to 45k
going into retirement for the two of you
and uh then everything else at the house
you're gonna have this house paid off
in about three more years
the only caveat to that is we've talked
about
um having a baby at some point in the
next year or two so I don't know like I
still plan to work at least part time
and I should be able to maintain like a
good chunk of my income but assuming we
end up let's worry about that when the
stork shows up yeah yeah
that's it for now for now let's just
execute this plan stork shows up you can
adjust your plan
okay but for right now I really think I
mean we're getting ready to throw 100
Grand at this house and you only owe 400
and you make 300. so I'm telling you you
probably are out of debt in about three
years and you're not that old how old
are y'all
uh I'm 26 who's 29. oh man you're doing
so good I mean Bridgette you're a rock
star and I you're so on top of it you
just need to take a deep breath and
realize there's no way you're going to
screw this up you're so responsible and
you guys your earning potential is going
to increase yeah you're making so much
money and you're gonna make more so
you're doing great this is good
everything is good but I'll tell you
what you're you're not getting good use
of that money is sitting over there
doing nothing in savings
because if you get this house paid off
it's kind of an unleash arithmetic into
your wealth building like you won't
believe what's your house worth
um so we bought it
um for like around it was like 605 what
we paid for it but
um it's worth a lot more now like that
was three years ago we bought it during
2020.
um so it says it's worth more and we've
actually put money into it like we've
renovated
um and like added square footage so is
it a million or more
um I I would guess around 900 would be
what it would sell for if I sold it like
put it on the market today that's
phenomenal now so you're Millionaires
and you're 26.
I mean I guess if you put
it just about just you're not quiet but
you're just about so you're doing a
really really good job so let's clean
that up and then you don't have that
burden of any kind when you're thinking
about things if a store comes or doesn't
come on on schedule then then hey we're
in good shape and we can adjust the plan
according if we want to and you've got
the flexibility to do that with a paid
for house that's where you're headed
that's where I'm going to take you to
because that's going to take you to a 10
million dollar net worth in the future
well done very cool you guys are amazing
so proud of you good good work man
you get started that age can the way the
math works it just blows your mind yeah
stupid it's stupid money I mean you said
it 10 million dollars is not an
exaggeration it's not hyperbole no it is
not I want people to understand that
that's very very doable wow great income
great Market where their home is to pay
off a house in a Boston Market are you
kidding me man that's big time that is
big time right there so yeah it's
amazing when you do when you pay
attention and that's what they're doing
they were paying attention before they
got to us yeah that's right and they're
being intentional it changes your whole
trajectory on your money
this state running around with your head
stuck in the clouds in chaos doesn't
work I just bought it because I fell and
shut up adults devise a plan and follow
it
children do what feels good this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on that debt free stage Matt and
Michelle are with us hey guys how are
you we're great Dave how are you better
than we deserve where do you guys live
just outside Milwaukee in Wisconsin oh
fun well welcome to Nashville thank you
and how much debt have you paid off 147
935 all right good for you and how long
did this take about 18 months good and
your range of income during that year
and a half started at about 210 000 and
now we're at 300 000. wow nice jump what
do you guys do for a living I'm in
healthcare sales and I work in Human
Resources cool so why the big 90 000
jump for me it was a couple of internal
promotions
um and then I'm very ambitious in my
career and took a couple extra jobs to
uh get that increased income ah look at
you well done well done so what kind of
debt was the 148. You Name It We
financed it you are not
straight normal yeah
um about 80 000 of it was student loans
fifty thousand in cars and then the rest
of it was anything from carpet to TVs to
couches you name it we did it you know I
hadn't thought about financing carpet in
a long time that used to happen a lot
though that's very yeah I get it okay
cool TVs even yeah okay everything
everything yeah I like it how long you
all been married
uh just about six years okay so a couple
years into the marriage just turns out
it's not going so good on the money part
what happened tell me the story here I
can see it coming yeah so I uh after we
got married I you know our communication
on money was was really poor I took sole
responsibility of kind of looking at our
finances and as you can see I was pretty
bad at it
obviously made a lot of poor decisions
and and then I would turn around and get
mad about a 90 Target or Walmart charge
yeah I know a guy like that and then uh
you know about two years ago I uh I woke
up on a Saturday morning beautiful day
with our kids in her home and instead of
hanging out with them I sat in our
office trying to figure out where all
our money was and totaled up all of our
debt I was kind of working the Avalanche
plan on our big student loan and
realized I dug a much bigger hole and so
uh
a few years before that someone at work
had told me about about you guys and I
never really took it seriously and so
that morning I Googled how do you get
out of debt easy and first name I saw
was yours and so I started listening and
uh probably three days later I called in
the show and uh you actually gifted me
financial piece on that day so wow yeah
so right around Father's Day a couple
years ago so I was on board right away
and then I had to get around to work
okay so he comes in and goes uh we have
a mess I made would you go to class with
me and what'd you say yeah it took me a
minute to get on board but once we
started watching some of the videos it
was actually Rachel that that kind of
put me on board she you know was very
relatable to me she was a mom with with
young kids who admittedly liked to shop
and spend and eat out so I said you know
what she does I said you know what it's
time it's time let's do it okay so you
got started watching Financial Peace
University together were you in a class
or just doing it at home did it all home
okay all right very cool very cool but
you did watch through the videos
together and then game on and every
little detail and uh and obviously 18
months that's pretty quick when you
first started this did you go 18 months
no way yeah pretty much you know there
was a lot of stuff wrong the way that we
kind of sacrificed on
um you know one of the things that we
did was I one of the cars was a you know
new 2020 GMC car and even though I we
had already paid it off I when all the
used cars went up oh yeah I actually
went and traded it in backwards for uh
you know 2013 and got a deal a deal and
they they handed me a check and it took
forever for them to go get it and they
were so apologetic and they're like
sorry normally people use their Equity
to trade up in car and um you know my
loudmouth said well normal's broke so
and then it took him another hour
so obviously a good income yeah so 210
going into this then you guys went into
hustle Zone you're busting it uh how
intense did this look and feel give us
give us the play-by-play when you really
get serious about it I think we realized
it was pretty serious when I came home
from a Costco trip and she realized that
I I turned in her name brand coffee for
the cheap stuff and she wasn't pretty
happy with me
yeah yeah that happened yeah a lot of
sacrifice you could trade your car and
don't mess with my car exactly that's
what I said
your car my coffee this is a problem yes
but yeah I think we just we started to
realize how much opportunity there was
in our budget to start really kind of
peeling back we weren't really budgeting
before that and so uh we started to
realize all the areas we had that we
could you know pull money out of and
um you know put it all towards that debt
do you remember how well if it was there
a month where you put the most away in
one month or was this a consistent
Rhythm once you got this thing figured
out
um I think it was you know obviously in
sales there's some ups and downs and
income but I think uh you know this past
year uh there was a significant bonus
that came through that was a uh man I
think it was like a twelve thousand
dollar payment or something like that so
you know fortunate for that for sure
yeah that's awesome yeah but then before
it would have just disappeared now it
went to the game plan yeah that was one
of the things that uh to me as I was
going through I had some notes in my
phone to make sure I stayed the course
and one of the things that I typed down
was every dollar is a dollar and what I
meant by that was just you know these 50
payments start to become 100 payments
and then you know it kind of adds up as
you go yep yep it does it does so
between the two of you now you've really
done it I mean you're you're not you're
not Theory you actually paid off a
hundred and forty eight thousand dollars
in 18 months so people that are out
there just thinking about this for the
first time they may be facing the that
fear you were facing on that Saturday
morning like oh crap I've made a mess
here uh what is the secret to getting
out of debt the two of you have done it
I think communication we started talking
a lot more about you know what our
upcoming expenses for the month you know
we've got three little kids and a lot of
expense comes along with that so what's
what's coming up in the next month and
not just those random you know fifty
hundred dollar payments at Target or
whatnot so the communication and just
the actual budgeting instead of swiping
the card and hoping it doesn't get
declined was was a big one yeah I mean
obviously you know the budget was huge
we we weren't doing it before so you
know what you know once we kind of
figure out what we would need from a
Target or Walmart or grocery store we
you know there was never any fights
about that we we had kind of dialed in
the budget and then uh the other thing
that I I certainly realized along the
way was that the the snowball is faster
than the Avalanche and you know again we
were trying I was focused so much on
just that student loan I didn't realize
how much of a hole I dug ourselves or we
dug ourselves as we uh focused on that
and all of a sudden that morning I
realized how much more we had gone into
debt so you also have to just stop going
into debt like that Saturday morning we
had a moment and said we're not done
we're done yeah that's it we're done
yeah and and
the power the powerful thing is when you
just make a decision like that it
changes the direction there it takes a
minute for the math to catch up but
something changes in the air I mean the
spirit changes you know and it's uh it's
it's powerful that's powerful well done
y'all y'all are heroes thank you that
was that was a hard 18 months yeah we we
actually you know our third baby was
born in January so we you know we've
cash flowed that as well along the way
and so uh the other piece of it too uh
you talk about peace all the time
we're moving our way through maybe step
three and we were almost done and our
car that hauls the whole family around
the engine went completely out and it
was wildly frustrating but like we
looked at each other and just said like
we're gonna be able we're gonna be okay
we got you know there's money in fix the
car fix the car no drama no drama just
uh used to be drama and broke and car
yeah and everything yeah oh my gosh Wow
way to go you guys very proud of y'all
y'all are heroes oh thank you well done
well done hey we've got the live and
give box for you that's the baby steps
millionaires book uh that's where you're
headed for sure if you're not there yet
you're gonna be there soon the way you
guys are rolling way to go and a
Financial Peace University membership
you've already got that so you'll be
able to give that away and of course a
Total Money Makeover and again that may
be something you give but it's up to you
it's your box we uh got it for you guys
to say thanks for coming all the way to
Nashville to do your debt free scream
we're proud of you at Ramsey thank you
you're why we do this so thank you very
much Matt and Michelle Milwaukee 148
paid off in 18 months making 210 to 300
counted down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're debt free
[Applause]
that can is a power couple man
boom yeah those two focus on something
their knee stopping them oh man boom I
love it I love it I love it Heroes well
done guys this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
our scripture of the day Matthew 6 34
therefore do not do be anxious about
tomorrow for tomorrow we'll be anxious
for itself sufficient
for the day is its own trouble
Winston Churchill said it is a mistake
to try to look too far ahead the chain
of Destiny can only be grasped one Link
at a time never heard that from
Churchill interesting very cool the dude
had a way of words didn't he he's a word
Smith Aspen is in College Station Texas
hi Aspen welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys thanks for taking my call and
all you guys are doing thank you how can
we help
um so I have kind of an interesting
question my husband is currently in
school to be a veteran
veterans we own our house debt free
except the mortgage except he will be
getting student loans hitting him right
when we leave so
when we sell our house we will have
about 130 in equity after the sale and
he'll owe about 160. I was wondering if
it would be okay to use about 40 000 of
that 130 as a down payment on a house
for when we move
um how much student loan debt does he
have
160. and we are currently paying on it
and I believe will be
about at 140 by the time when you get
140 out of the house so you could be
clear if you if you just wait to buy a
house
yes yes I would I would be clear of the
student loans
okay that's not what you wanted to hear
but I would be no because I think I
think that here's what's going to happen
okay you're coming out of school you're
resetting everything in your mind
you're resetting everything in your life
all the math in your life is changing
you're going from being a student piling
up debt to clearing debt and starting to
have some serious money and uh do you
know where he's going to be working yet
as he got that lined up
yes so he's already signed a contract
and he will start off at 1 30. I am
currently working full time so we're
living off my salary right now which is
more than enough so how much is your
salary
95 and it'll be the same when you move
it'll
like for a promotion and hopefully in
the fall I think it'll be closer to 110.
so you guys are going to be making a
quarter of a million dollars
with not a debt in the world
and I'm saying rent for a year rent for
a year and pile up a huge pile of cash
and then go buy something you will buy
something different than you would
stealing this forty thousand away from
the student loan debt and trying to
squeak into a house to go from house to
house
instead of renting for one year you're
moving to a new market you'll know the
market better you can take your time in
the purchase you'll have the income
stabilized your lives will be stabilized
you're going to do a lot better real
estate deal a lot more accurate real
estate deal for the next five years than
you will do if you do what you're
thinking
yeah but your friends are going to think
you're crazy
no they already think we're crazy it's
okay that's okay they're broke and
understand your your parents may say the
same thing oh you guys need to put a
down payment but let me tell you
something when we moved I had three
little ones uh they were all let's see
eight
um call it six and and five when we
moved here nine years ago and Stacy and
I rented for two years because we wanted
to save up a larger down payment and two
we wanted to get a lay of the land to
figure out where we were gonna plant
here and so it's it is not unwise to
rent can I just tell you it gives you
options for a short period of time yeah
short period of time and two's on the
long end but it worked for us yeah yeah
and you know like I'm saying one year
here you're gonna know the market better
you'll take your time in the purchase
you'll you'll make a much better
purchase and your brain is going to be
in a different place making a quarter of
a million than it was vet school and 90.
so true and it you know you'll adjust
you'll go okay this is the right you're
gonna make a better
house decision that's more
forward-looking than jumping to Jumping
yeah and and
um but but everybody's so strung out
about real estate I love real estate and
I want you to be a homeowner but I want
you to do it the right way Lee is with
us or Leah in uh Boston hi Leah how are
you yeah hey how are you thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um I am 43 I just turned 43 and I am
thinking of going back to school for my
NP
um nurse practitioner
um and I just became actually this is
all my second career being a nurse
um and
um I'm I'm thinking about how to pay for
it it's about 50 Grand
and I could pay outright for it
however my income when I'm in school
although it's part time will go down a
little bit as well because I won't be
working as much
um so I can pay for it but in my mind I
get scared to do that and I'm more
tempted to take out loans so you feel
like you'll be more secure going into
debt
then you would be secure with a little
less money
you're wrong
I know I'm wrong I know I'm wrong that's
the thing you know I'm also I'm also I'm
I'm also a mom
um I have one 12 year old
um
How much money how much money have you
got in the bank Leah
um I have about like 295 yeah and you're
gonna spend and you're going to spend
what on the on the uh the nurse
practitioner 50 50. about 50 give it a
little probably a little bit over 50.
but you realize how ridiculous the
question of the numbers you just gave me
are don't you no but the difference in
295 and 250.
right 245. my in terms of taking care of
a 12 year old is laughable
oh but if you burn through 245 you're
going to burn through 295. I love this
back and forth you've gone to the butt
three times and Dave's interrupt you I
got to hear this butt what is the butt
but I have you know expenses my rent is
is expensive yeah princess died
[Laughter]
a quarter of a million dollars of
expenses
well no I mean I have you know I
I am I I had I made a lot more money
before this career now I've gone down
because I hated my job before and now I
love my job but it came out okay so Leah
hold on one second let's look at how
much what are you gonna make less as
you're going into school how much less
will you make have you got that figured
out as take home how's it going to
change um foreign
I well I used to make over three hundred
thousand no that's not what we're
talking about no you said you used to
make a million but that doesn't matter
what do you make now that's going to go
down yeah I I bring home about
um between
seven and eight thousand a month and you
would instead you'll be bringing home
how much yeah
okay so two thousand a month that's
twenty four thousand dollars
can you adjust your lifestyle to where
that's not stressing you out or pull
twenty four thousand out of your 295.
there's the pull 50 out of your 295. and
keep everything exactly like it is right
now and go to school without environment
you do not need to borrow money it's
Insanity with your numbers there's also
there's also the okay you need to go
borrow money you should go deeply in
debt I'm tired of arguing with you you
should go deeply in debt and see if you
can bankrupt yourself yeah oh my God
woman how many times have I got to argue
with you this is nuts
he's fighting hard for that loan right
now I'm desperate to go into student
loan debt well go at it lady go at it
that's what you need to do oh my gosh
yeah how in the world you you're sitting
on three hundred thousand dollars cash
and your biggest worry is a twenty four
thousand dollar shortfall and a
twelve-year-old
geez you you're okay yeah you're okay
because she didn't get you didn't get
there with being crazy and undisciplined
to stack that kind of cash away but she
got there because she had a huge income
because she did but she still saved it
you know it's not like she's gonna just
blow this cash but no we don't borrow
money to preserve a savings account
so no no no no how many times I gotta
say this no no Ken good show today thank
you sir that was fun Austin Ben James
Zack and Andrew in the booth well done
guys well done that puts this hour the
Ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]